go hello my name is Angus your Kron
jawala and I'm the coordinating minister
for the economy and finance minister for
Nigerian hello from Davos you asked
about what if we think the global
economy will be like in three five and
ten years from now what could we do to
make it better I think in three five
nine ten years from now we'll continue
to see that growth in the global economy
is driven largely by emerging market
countries like India China Brazil and
increasingly another group of countries
in the Middle such as mine like Nigeria
Mexico Colombian others like that and I
think that they're going to push global
growth I think Africa will be much more
dynamic a more prominent but there is
also a phenomenon I think will be
important and that will be that they'll
be more and more of a gap between the
rich and the poor between rich countries
and poor countries and also between rich
people and poor people and I think that
what we could do to make it better we
need to think of ways and means in which
it can be much more inclusive of those
at the bottom of the matter so as an
individual I would ask you an a young
person to think of projects that you can
do within your own country but to reach
down to people who earned much for a
bracket to help them become better and
Howard helped to help themselves so that
individually and collectively as
policymakers we can begin to close this
gap between rich people and poor people
policymakers have to do much more with
in their countries today direct
resources towards the poor but
individuals can also do something to
help those who are less privileged than
themselves thank